[Musik]
hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von mir ich wollte heute
eigentlich mal wieder auf nickel
hochladen also wie ich mit euch
videochat allerdings ist regel gerade
dauern weil ihr zug rast auf die server
gegangen seid deswegen habe ich mich
jetzt hier für chatroulette entschieden
und ich muss erstmal meine kamera
aktivieren ich wollte ja eigentlich auf
einem kanal in der regel bringen weil
das coole daran ist dass ich mit euch
quasi skypen kann mehr oder weniger
allerdings bei chatroulette ist es halt
so dass man nicht irgendwie räume
erstellen kann wo man sagen kann okay
jetzt kommt hier jeder reihen der
irgendwie luca als interessen gibt
sondern man skype wirklich mit komplett
zufälligen menschen auf der welt aber
das machen wir jetzt quasi mal als
ausweich heute mein gott oh mein gott
ja
das war der grund warum ich das nie
gemacht habe
wir geben dem ganzen mann noch im
zweiten versuch hier steht jetzt
connecting partner das heißt das ganze
lebt jetzt hier vorne und
o
rückt
[Musik]
diese drückt uns denn jeder weg
moment jeder hier ist nackt soll ich
mich jetzt auch aktiv vorsätzen ein paar
sekunden später
[Musik]
das ist doch nicht war und man eben wie
das t shirt anziehen ich musste bisher
von vier leuten die wir getroffen haben
drei zensieren
was ist los mit dieser plattform ich
habe jetzt mal wieder statt geklickte
wir schauen jetzt mal ob diesmal
eventuell jemand kommt mit dem wir so
wirklich reden können hey hey you
ich verstehe nicht wo man schon mal so
ein kurzes zwischenfazit zu ziehen
entweder sind die user der plattform
chat roulette nackt oder sie haben kein
mikro
oder ich hatte einfach nicht an hey
hey you think ja drückt mich weg alles
klar
[Musik]
dj
was schauen was jetzt der nächste
partner hat okay das ist wieder das
wieder irgendwie nackt oder so also mal
schauen konnten jetzt haben wir den
anderen nicht dass euch jetzt mal an crd
mit dabei film zu einem bade geklickt
uns natürlich auch direkt weg freunde
ich meine natürlich logisch mit uns will
natürlich auch keiner reden er hat heute
sein bauch drückt uns natürlich auch
wieder weg ist es wirklich vollkommen in
ordnung das betrifft mich jetzt auch gar
nicht mal persönlich abwehr haben wir
schon den nächsten alles klar
mal wieder ein penis herkommen oder wenn
man frieden machen dann geht
auch nicht nächster partner hier immer
wieder es lädt der film ganz nach seine
drückt natürlich weg also freunde dass
ich weiß ich hab mich einfach so
hässlich finden dass eventuell ein
browser liegt aber ich versuche jetzt
mal mit internet explorers etliche
browser ist nazi portland ladies welchen
auf krampf ich hab doch die latest
version of chrome grad gehabt klingt
jetzt wieder auf start befinde mich
jetzt hier wieder in dem chrome browser
drin und wir schauen was jetzt unser
nächster partner zu sagen hat
ich weiß nicht ob ich traurig bin dass
ich keinen ton habe weil mit ein paar
leuten hätte ich mich echt gern bisschen
unterhalten aber auf der anderen seite
bin ich auch irgendwie froh dass ich
keinen ton habe weil da waren schon echt
komische menschen ich gebe dem ganzen
jetzt noch eine chance und ich würde
sagen dass wir uns noch fünf leute hier
anschauen
connecting tour partner das ganze lädt
hier wieder wir sehen
drück mich weckte partner mal schauen
was der nächste ein penis es geht direkt
weiter wir sehen wieder den
ladebildschirm und wie ich bin gespannt
was wir jetzt holen
hi
die vierte person lebt jetzt hier gerade
auch ist
einfach ein leerer stuhl die letzte
person die wir uns
schon werden meine damen und herren ich
bin gespannt was uns jetzt hier erwarten
wird das ganze lied schon und wir sehen
warum warum warum
[Musik]